Welcome to the second
lesson in native Ling. Dot.
Comes course on language
change in language history.
This time around we're going to look
at the kinds of concepts we need to be
familiar with in order to evaluate whether
or not two languages are related and
how they're related,
how closely they're related.
The first thing we need to consider is
what part of language are we going to be
looking at?
What part of a language are we going to
be comparing and through trial and error
it seems the best practice that's been
established is to look at what's known as
basic core vocabulary.
Basic core vocabulary is a range of words,
vocabulary items that stand for common
concepts including family members
including basic concepts that
are found in nature, animals,
pronouns,
very common everyday items that at least
in theory aren't replaced very much and
are passed down to the next generation
of speakers early and often will also
need to know what to look for when we
compare the basic core vocabulary of one
language to another.
When we look at vocabulary items,
which are just single words.
What we'll find is that when
two languages are related,
they'll share a resemblance,
a common root.
So the two vocabulary items
will ultimately derived
from the same common sorts.
We use the word common to mean that
at one time they weren't the same,
but they diverged over time in different
areas, in different speech communities,
into distinct words in
two different languages.
But suffice it to say that cognate is
just a term for saying that these two are
related words that come
from some common ancestor.
That's what we're looking for
to establish a relationship,
but that's not the only reason that two
words would look similar to words might
also look similar to each
other due to chance. In other
words, randomly over time,
especially with small words in languages,
we'll find that similar words.
Similar sounding words will
stand for similar concepts,
so we might find that the word for water
and one language resembles the word in
a completely unrelated language and the
two words may not be related at all.
When one language comes into
contact with another language,
it often borrows words from that
other language. It takes words,
especially for concepts that it doesn't
already have. For example, in English,
we borrow the word cafe from French cafe.
The two words aren't genuine.
Cognates that developed independently
in English and French rather.
English speakers at some point
borrowed the word cafe from French.
The same analysis helps us when we look
at the basic core vocabulary list of
English.
We have a word person.
The word person is a fairly basic word,
yet it was actually borrowed.
It's a native dramatic word in
English. Well, it's a native word now,
but it was at some point
borrowed into English,
so when we find languages like Spanish,
Italian and French that
inherited this word from Latin,
we can't genuinely say, let's compare the
English cognate to the French cognate,
where the English cognate to the
Spanish cognate because at some point,
English borrowed that word,
whereas the other languages inherited it.
At this point,
you have some understanding of cognates
and language and an understanding of
similarities that will show up due
to things other than cognitive.
Namely borrowing and chance.
Now we'll be able to move on and compare
individual languages and start to look
at family relationship.